THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH, BUT THE
TOPIC IS BOUND TO COME UP.
IT COME AS MANY REPUBLICANS ARE
LASHING OUT AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I WANT TO BRING IN CONGRESSMAN
MIKE TURNER OF OHIO.
HE'S THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, AND HE
SENT A LETTER TO THE FBI
DIRECTOR CALLING ON HIM TO
EXPLAIN HIS DECISION TO
AUTHORIZE THE SEARCH.
HI, CONGRESSMAN.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU STILL HAVEN'T HEARD BACK
FROM THE FBI FROM THE LETTER YOU
SENT.
WHAT ARE NEXT STEPS IF YOU DON'T
HEAR BACK?
>> WELL, WE HAVE ALREADY BEGUN
TO ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTATION.
OUR FIRST LETTER TO DIRECTOR
WRAY WAS TO ASK HIM WHAT
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK ROSE TO
THE LEVEL OF HIM ORDERING A RAID
ON THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
AND IN HISTORY, WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN TWO MEMBERS OF A
PRESIDENT'S ADMINISTRATION ORDER
A RAID ON THE PRESIDENT'S
POLITICAL RIVAL, HIS FORMER
OPPONENT AND PERHAPS POTENTIAL
OPPONENT.
CERTAINLY, WHATEVER THEY'RE
SEARCHING FOR MUST RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT FOR THE DIRECTOR TO HAVE
ORDERED A RAID ON HIS HOME.
WE ASKED IN IN ADDITION, WE WANT
TO SEE, THIS IS REPORTEDLY ABOUT
THE ARCHIVIST SENDING OVER A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT THAT IS.
WE ALSO WANT TO SEE WHAT
CHRISTOPHER WRAY FILED IN COURT,
WHAT HE SAID TO THE COURT HE WAS
GOING TO FIND THERE, AND AN
INVENTORY OF WHAT THEY FOUND.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD IN REPORTS
THAT EVEN PERSONAL MATERIALS OF
THE PRESIDENT WERE TAKEN.
WHAT WERE THEY LOOKING FOR, WHAT
DID THEY FIND, AND WHAT DID THEY
TELL THE COURT THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR?
>> THERE'S STILL A LOT WE'RE
HOPING TO LEARN.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN THE MAJORITY
IN THE MIDTERMS.
WHAT WOULD OVERSIGHT LOOK LIKE?
>> WELL, THE AMERICAN PUBLIC ARE
GOING TO REQUIRE, OBVIOUSLY, A
REVIEW HERE.
YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE TWO MEN WHO
ARE IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
GO AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
POLITICAL RIVAL AND NOT HAVE THE
TYPE OF SCRUTINY THAT IS GOING
TO BE NECESSARY HERE.
WE NEED TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
APPROPRIATE LAWS WERE FOLLOWED.
THESE TWO GENTLEMEN ARE HELD TO
OVERSIGHT, AND THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WANTS TO KNOW.
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
STANDARDS HERE WHERE HILLARY
CLINTON --
>> I WANT TO STOP YOU --
>> HOLD ON.
WE HAVE TWO STANDARDS WHERE WE
HAVE HILLARY CLINTON WITH HER
OWN COMPUTER SYSTEM AND
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON IT
BEING GIVEN A SUBPOENA AND THE
ABILITY TO GO THROUGH THAT
SERVER TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S PERSONAL MATERIAL OR
OFFICIAL MATERIAL.
AND THIS PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT,
NOT A SECRETARY OF STATE, BEING
RAIDED.
CLEARLY TWO DIFFERENT STANDARDS
AND WE WANT TO KNOW WHY.
>> HOLD ON A SECOND ETHORX
EBECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
SECRETARY CLINTON, THERE'S A LOT
TO BREAK DOWN FROM WHAT YOU
SAID, BUT LET'S GO TO THE LAST
PART.
SECRETARY CLINTON, YOU AT THE
TIME INDICATED THAT YOU WERE
OUTRAGED BY HER -- THE WAY SHE
HANDLED HER CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, SAYING SECRETARY
CLINTON CAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HER EXTREMELY CARELESS
ACTIONS.
SO WHY DON'T YOU SHARE THAT SAME
CONCERN WITH DONALD TRUMP WHO IS
NOW A PRIVATE CITIZEN TAKING 15
BOXES OF DOCUMENTS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE INCLUDING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS TO THE WHITE HOUSE, TO
HIS PRIVATE RESIDENCE?
WHY WAS IT CONCERNING FOR YOU
WITH HILLARY CLINTON AND NOT NOW
WITH DONALD TRUMP?
>> SURE, THEY ARE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS.
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON, WHILE SHE
WAS SECRETARY OF STATE, HAD
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ABOUT HER
CLASSIFIED COMMUNICATIONS
TRAVELING THROUGH HER COMPUTER
SERVER IN HER HOUSE, PUTTING IT
AT RISK FOR ANY
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OR ANY
OTHERS WHO ARE HACKING INTO HER
MATERIALS, PUTTING THE UNITED
STATES MATERIALS AT RISK.
IN THIS INSTANCE, WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW THAT THESE
INFORMATIONS ARE CLASSIFIED.
THE ARCHIVISTS SAYING THAT
SOMETHING IS LABELED CLASSIFIED
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT IS.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
SUBSTANCE OF WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS.
THESE AREN'T ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ON DIPLOMACY
MATTERS THAT HILLARY CLINTON WAS
CONDUCTING THROUGH HER HOME, AND
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES UNLIKE HILLARY CLINTON
HAS THE ABILITY TO DECLASSIFY
THE MATERIALS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE STATUS
OF THESE MATERIALS ARE.
THAT'S WHY THE FBI DIRECTOR
NEEDS TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, WHAT DID HE GO AFTER.
THERE MUST BE SOMETHING HIGHER
ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY LEVEL
FOR HIM TO DO THIS.
REMEMBER, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
MORE CLASSIFIED MATERIAL IN HIS
HEAD THAN HE'S GOING TO HAVE IN
HIS DESK.
BUT YET THEY RAIDED HIS HOME TO
SEE WHAT HE HAD IN HIS DESK.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WANT
ANSWERS.
>> THEY EXKUPTED A SEARCH
WARRANT THAT WAS SIGNED OFF BY A
JUDGE WHO CLEARLY FOUND PROBABLE
CAUSE.
BUT REALLY QUICK, I WANT TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT, BUT EARLIER IN
THE CONVERSATION, YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT, YOU WERE CLAIMING
THAT DOJ IS BASICALLY GOING
AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL
RIVAL, BUT DONALD TRUMP, THERE
IS EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE, I
THINK THERE ARE LIKE 25 EXAMPLES
OF HIM WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT
TRYING TO WEAPONIZE DOJ TO GO
AFTER HIS POLITICAL RIVALS.
SO WHY DO YOU FEEL LIKE THERE
SHOULD BE MORE SCUTEANY NOW ON
DOJ AND NOT ALSO, AND WE SEE IT
ON THE SCREEN HERE AS WELL, NOT
ALSO SHARE THAT SAME CONCERN
BACK THEN WHEN TRUMP WAS TRYING
TO GO AFTER HIS POLITICAL
RIVALS?
>> I HAVE SHARED IT.
THIS GOES BACK TO THE
OBAMA/BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHERE
THIS CLAPPER, BRENNAN, COMEY,
WHERE THEY BEGAN THE
POLITICALIZATION OF THE FBI AND
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND WHERE WE SAW THE TWO
STANDARDS, WHERE HILLARY CLINTON
WAS GIVEN A PASS AND OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE MILITARY
WERE NOT.
AND CERTAINLY THEN YOU HAD
DONALD TRUMP WHO CONTINUED TO
RAISE THAT ISSUE OF WHAT WERE
THESE TWO STANDARDS, WHY WAS HE
BEING PURSUED, AND AS YOU EVEN
NOTE TODAY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAS REPORTED THAT EVEN THE
RUSSIA DOSSIER THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE USED TO
IDENTIFY FISA TAPABLE WARRANTS
WAS FOUND TO BE TOTALLY NOT EVEN
FACTUAL, SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WERE
ONGOING DURING HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
AND CERTAINLY WE'RE SEEING THEM
NOW CONTINUE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> BUT THERE WERE EXAMPLES OF 25
TIMES WHERE HE WANTED TO USE THE
DOJ TO GO AFTER POLITICAL
RIVALS.
SOME WITH ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
AT ALL TO SUPPORT WANTING TO
UUSE DOJ, DUT I DO WANT TO GO
BACK AND TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
YOU SHARE A CONCERN, LIKE A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS DO, SAYING THIS
IS FBI OVERREACH.
BUT AGAIN, THIS WAS A SEARCH
WARRANT THAT WAS EXECUTED AFTER
A FEDERAL JUDGE SIGNED OFF,
FINDING PROBABLE CAUSE.
SO IS YOUR ISSUE WITH HOW THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS?
I MEAN, WHAT IS IT EXACTLY THAT
YOU --
>> PAMELA.
RIGHT, SO THIS IS ACTUALLY VERY
EASY, AND YOU WERE NEVER
DISCUSSING THIS BEFORE.
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN DONE IN OUR
HISTORY TO A FORMER PRESIDENT, A
POLITICAL RIVAL OF THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
THESE TWO GENTLEMEN RAN AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND DONALD TRUMP SAID
HE MIGHT RUN AGAINST BIDEN EVEN
NOW, AND BIDEN SAID HE MIGHT
RUN.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHETHER HE DOES.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE POLITICAL
RIVAL OF THE SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> SO YOU THINK DOJ IS JUST
GOING AFTER -- HOLD ON, I WANT
TO BE CLEAR.
YOU -- HOLD ON, HOLD ON,
CONGRESSMAN.
I'M TRYING TO GIVE YOU THE TIME
TO CONVEY WHAT YOU WANT TO
CONVEY, BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR
HERE.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY HERE
IS YOU BELIEVE THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS TRYING TO GO AFTER HIS
POLITICAL RIVAL DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE OF 2024?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SAY HERE?
>> NO, PAMELA.
I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
THANKS FOR TRYING TO PUT WORDS
IN MY MOUTH.
>> NO, I DID NOT TRY TO.
I'M TRYING TO CLARIFY.
>> WHAT I SAID IS THEY NEED TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS.
THERE BETTER BE SOMETHING OF
IMPORTANT NATIONAL SECURITY FOR
THEM TO HAVE BREACHED THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IF THEY WOULD GO INTO THE
HOME OF A PAST PRESIDENT,
POSSIBLE POLITICAL CANDIDATES
AGAINST THIS CURRENT PRESIDENT.
THIS IS SO OUTRAGEOUS THAT THIS
HAS TO RISE TO THE LEVEL OF THIS
BETTER NOT BE A CLERICAL ISSUE
BETWEEN THE ARCHIVIST AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
EVEN FORMER NEW YORK GOVERNOR
CUOMO HAS SAID THE SAME THING
I'M SAYING ON YOUR SHOW, IS THAT
THIS BETTER NOT BE SOME CLERICAL
ISSUE OR SOME MINOR ISSUE THAT
THE FBI HAS GONE IN.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING, AS
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
WE'RE IN CHARGE OF CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL.
WE'RE IN CHARGE OF THE ISSUE OF
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES AND
SECRETS OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF THEY'RE GOING INTO THIS MAN'S
HOUSE CLAIMING THAT IT'S
NATIONAL SECURITY THAT BROUGHT
THEM IN, THEN THEY DESERVE TO
TELL US.
THEY DESER